new state gun legislation is headed to
the desk of Florida Governor Rick Scott
this morning after last month's deadly
school shooting in parkland he has not
said if he will sign it Florida
lawmakers voted for final approval of
the bill last night it raises the age to
buy rifles increases mental health
resources and allows some teachers to be
armed the accused gunman was formally
charged yesterday with 17 counts of
first degree murder and 17 counts of
attempted murder Adriana Diaz is at the
State Capitol in Tallahassee Adriana
good morning good morning the state
representative who introduced this
measure in the house as it pushed both
Republicans and Democrats beyond their
comfort level the families of all 17
victims supported the bill and they
wrote this letter to lawmakers to tell
them so 67 days 15 days mr. speaker so
the bill passes read the next bill
lawmakers say they kept their promise
passing legislation in the name of the
17 people who died at Marjory Stoneman
Douglas High School Andrew Pollock's 18
year old daughter meadow was killed in
the shooting it's important for the
country to unite in the same way the 17
families united in support of this bill
Republican state representative Jose
Oliva introduced the measure in the
house I know that some of you think that
this is gonna put guns in schools and
kill children I would not be standing
here if I thought that that was the case
the bill would limit rifle sales to
people 21 or over after a three day
waiting period allocate 400 million
dollars for provisions like school
mental health programs and allow some
teachers to be armed the question of
arming school staff has fueled days of
debate a black a brown boy who may be
running down the hall to get away like
everyone else who reaches for his cell
phone to call his parents may be seen by
the Guardian not as a student but as the
shooter a lot of the students have
actually came at this state house have
called for a ban on assault rifles and
for teachers not to be armed or staff
members not to be armed this bill does
neither of those things
we've met with many students and parents
and
including the parents of the 17 that
were slain all of them have signed a
letter urging everyone to support this
legislation only teachers who don't
teach full-time can be armed so like a
teacher who also coaches and that's only
in the counties that allow it the bill
now goes to the desk of Republican
Governor Rick Scott who opposes arming
teachers
he says he'll read it line by line and
consult with victims families before
deciding whether or not to sign it
gale a lot of people watching that very
closely thank you very much Adriana